there is a fascinating audio recording
that has been leaked in which a
prominent Republican is caught saying
that Donald Trump is quote killing us
meaning killing not even necessarily
Republicans but even some trumpian
Republicans in important local races and
this is a riveting peek behind the
curtain in the chaos of the Republican
Party under Donald Trump the Texas
Republican House Speaker Dennis Bonin is
on a radio on an audio recording rather
asking for help out stting members of
his own Republican party in 2020
he's on recording calling a female
lawmaker vile and saying that Donald
Trump is quote killing us now Democrats
have filed a lawsuit that accuses Bonin
of breaking campaign finance laws who
isn't breaking campaign finance laws
these days right and there is also a
state probe into allegations of
corruption this meeting was secretly
recorded by the CEO of a group called
empower Texans which is a far-right
group whose CEO Michael Quinn Sullivan
said the reason I recorded it was to
protect myself
which is also a very interesting detail
in all of this and this is all happening
because Republicans are at risk of
losing control of the Texas House as you
probably know if you follow politics
Texas is a historically conservative
state although there have been shades of
purple more and more recently
particularly in some Eric areas but
regardless Republicans have controlled
the Texas House for almost two decades
and now Republicans are in a position
where they could lose control of the
house if they lose nine seats to
Democrats in 2020 many Republicans are
panicking and Bannen is blaming Donald
Trump he says on the recording with all
due respect to Trump who I love he's
killing us in urban suburban districts
now this warrants some thought is it
true that Donald Trump is killing them
the answer is very regional it may well
be that in Texas in urban and suburban
districts Trump is hurting the brand of
Republicans that
Bannen is a part of in some parts of the
country it's not that clear although
increasingly including in North Carolina
which will we've already dealt with on
today's show Trump is certainly not
helping ultimately if Trump destroys the
Republican Party as we know it or at
least seriously hurts it for a decade it
is their fault they voted for him they
are choosing this rope to hang
themselves with if ultimately it is what
they hang themselves with but it's up to
us to make it happen and I've talked
about that already there's another thing
to point out dennis Bannen and the
contingent in texas that is trying to
get other republicans removed from
office this is an extreme group of
republicans dennis Bannen loves Trump
but he claims to recognize that Donald
Trump is hurting them what Dennis Bannen
and his cronies are trying to do is
remove what are some of the more
moderate Texas Republicans and replace
them with unhinged trumpian lunatics he
merely recognizes or at least believes
that Donald Trump is hurting their cause
to do that we should not mistake this
for Bannen being the moderate Bannen is
an absolute maniac and in the end we get
to the same place as nationally on this
issue if we vote we can do good things
if we vote nationally in November of
2020 we can remove Trump we have the
numbers it's a question of how many of
those numbers will turn up at the ballot
box
if Texan Democrats vote they can
potentially flip Texas blue which would
be an accomplishment of stunning
historic proportions if we don't vote if
they if you Texas Democrats don't vote
then everything stays the same or
potentially gets even worse and in the
end I mean it's like you know when you
have an election with so many different
factors Russian meddling problems with
voting machines social media campaigns
and echo chambers right-wing media
perpetuating the feedback loops through
algorithmic of echo chambers all of the
stuff we've talked about it is really
you know Hillary not going to Wisconsin
in the last days of the race when you
have elections that hinge
on under a hundred thousand votes in
three states it's very hard to say this
is the one thing that decided the
results because there are so many other
things that could have changed them the
one part that is completely clear is
that if voter turnout wasn't fifty
percent if the left just got out and
voted in droves the answer is none of
those little things matter none of those
medium-sized things matter because we
just have the numbers now of course the
opposite is true if we don't vote and
the right is able to invigorate their
base and get out and vote we don't stand
a chance and that's why ultimately you
can point to any point to blame whatever
you want for 2016 in a pragmatic sense
Hillary not campaigning correctly
towards the end Russian meddling fear of
losing status racism blame anything you
want but know that we can over we we can
outdo the impact of all of those
elements by increasing voter turnout
which sounds like it should be easy to
do and it never quite works out
unfortunately